I want to take just a moment here to
introduce a new sponsor for our show
yeah this is uh this is a sponsor for
the program it's brand new folks if
you're into online fantasy sports sites
like draftkings and FanDuel I think
you'll really enjoy this hot new service
take a look
everyone's talking about spend kings.com
the easiest way to spend money online
spending money so easy to spend Kings
calm you just log in and pick him out
you want to spend with span kings you
can spend $1 $100 or all of your dollars
it's up to you just log in to span Kings
comm enter your credit card information
and choose the amount you want to spend
just click and spend if you want to
spend more you just click again spend
Kings is really flexible it's up to me
how much I want to spend you can even
use at relative's bank account if you
get them to give you the info now and
enter the promo code Robin and will
double the amount you spend I entered
the public owed and spent Kings took
twice the amount I wanted to spend it
was really exciting this week I spent
$75 is that good it's great yours been
key but what do I get for the money I
spent you're a winner
you you on yours Benji okay sweet once a
week we'll randomly select one lucky
spend came to spend 1 million dollars
[Applause]
the more you spend
I'm sending I'm a spanking
[Applause]
bad game hey thanks for watching be sure
to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography